[Music]
the agonizing wait for the body of a
loved one
this is the family of ihab al-wazini a
well-known organizer in iraq's
intergovernment protest movement
he was shot dead the night before just
outside his home in iraq's southern city
of karbala
ihab's mother told al-jazeera he had
received numerous threats from
paramilitary groups backed by iran
the militias are everywhere in the
streets they have a list which includes
the names of all the activists
they will kill them one by one today
they killed my son
and soon they'll kill another the
funeral procession arrived in the
scorching afternoon heat
their religious oaks punctuated with
desperate cries for survival
the parties are killing us scream the
men who once stood by ihab's side in
kerball's protest squares demanding
change
but is anyone listening inside ehab's
family said their final goodbye
their anger directed at both the killers
and the government
who failed to protect him we don't trust
the government
and we don't trust this political
process if there's to be justice
there should be an international
investigation ehab is one of 34
activists assassinated since protests
first began in october 2019
according to iraq's human rights
commission a third were killed after a
new government was formed in may 2020
promising to end impunity when prime
minister mustafa al-qaeda me came to
power almost a year ago
he promised to reign in armed groups
that acted outside of the state's
control
and to bring those responsible for the
deaths of protesters and activists to
account
but only a handful of arrests have been
made and no one
has been convicted and so the killings
and the funerals go
on the protesters drove ihab's body to
catabola central square
once packed with crowds rallying for a
cause
but after the movement crumbled amid
brutal repression
they mostly just gathered to mourn those
they lost
few here dare to speak on camera in fear
they might be next
some expect violence to further flare
ahead of october elections
these assassinations don't come out of
nowhere they are organized
it's linked to the elections that have
been set for next october and all these
politicians are scared
and think that october protesters will
compete for their power to bring about
change
that's why they're targeting the
activist and today he had paid the price
the prime minister promised justice and
ordered an
inquiry but none of these investigations
have borne fruit in the past
leaving little hope for accountability
in the future
simona faltin al-jazeera kerbala